each year Microsoft Research hosts
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely available
to my pleasure to introduce Emerson
Murphy hill he is got his PhD from
portland state and then spent two years
at UBC under Gail Murphy as a postdoc
and just recently started as assistant
professor at North Carolina State so
he's visiting us today and they'll also
be around for the rest of the week so if
anybody like to send them questions by
email of people watching over video or
meet with him you can email me Miami
bird or Emerson directly so that
will turn it over to him okay thanks
Chris and thanks for inviting me happy
to be here thank you for all all of you
for taking your morning to come and see
me talk so I wanted to talk about why
software developers don't use their
tools and I want to start by telling you
a little story so this is the PDP one
computer and this came out almost
exactly 50 years ago and this is a this
is a replica I think this is from the
computer history museum in san jose and
so the computer you see in the back with
the monitor is some later some waiter
computer and came out about 50 years ago
cost about a hundred thousand dollars it
came out with kind of one of what what
you might consider the first editor they
they didn't know have an official name
for it but they called it the colossal
typewriter or the very expensive
typewriter and what's interesting to me
about this system is that although it's
got an editor and although you could do
some programming on it there wasn't
actually a monitor to see what you were
programming ok and if you wanted to type
something in and then see what you had
what you had written you have to use the
printer and there's a little printer in
the back alright so which of course
makes you know debugging your programs a
bit of a challenge so you know if
anybody tells you that real programmers
don't use visual studio they use Emacs
you can tell them the real programmers
don't use either of those they don't
even use a screen so i put in to bring
up this example just because i want to
say that you know 50 years ago this is
maybe gives you kind of an idea of what
software development
looked like and it was fairly you know
you could you could do your job but it
was fairly primitive okay there's a
limited amount of things you could do a
limited amount of tools that were
available to you so contrast that with
today so this is what may be an average
software developers workstation looks
like we've gone from you know having all
computer and no screen to basically all
screen and very little computer and we
have a million a thousand different
tools at our fingertips we have bug
trackers we have integrated development
environments where we can you know
format our source code with a with it
with a single key press we can get an
outline of our code we can navigate our
code we can find call hierarchies we can
we can find references we can change the
structure of our code we can generate
new code there's a million at a million
there's there's thousands of different
tools within within eclipse or Visual
Studio or any you know modern integrated
development environment and so the point
of this example is that I'd say life has
really changed technologically we have a
lot more at our fingertips as software
developers there's a lot more things
that we can do however if you look at
all of the different software features
that are available say in Eclipse all
right and you look at how many people
are actually using the number is quite
small so most developers use less than
1% of the available commands and eclipse
and so how we know this is eclipse makes
public its usage data so if you use
eclipse and you agree to submit your
usage data each time you use a command
eclipse records it and then puts it on a
server and the Eclipse Foundation so we
can go through that data and see which
commands people are using and also kind
of inference are not using question
software tools like word yes good so I
don't know anything about other
development environments I know my guess
visual studio is keeping track and I
know intellij is keeping track too but i
think that's that's private i believe
there's public word data from maybe 10
years ago non programming tools it's
actually quite similar quite similar as
well i don't know if it's may be quite
as Extreme as this but take you know
take another example outside of outside
of programming like the the the apple
app store okay how many pieces of
software in the app store do you use of
the 100,000 that are available maybeee
maybe if you use a lot you use a hundred
right so it's pretty small yeah is it
the same one percent no there's you know
for any tool you'll probably find a good
one or two users now some of them are
very esoteric and very few people know
about them so for example in Eclipse
there's a tool called hippie complete
okay it's like auto complete it has a
history I don't I don't remember what it
is exactly but it comes from it from a
previous editor and the way hippie
complete works it's like it's a
brain-dead autocomplete doesn't know
anything about the semantics of your
program but if you're typing on a token
okay it looks back at the previous few
letters you've typed all right and then
finds that token in the previous
basically looks the previous code or the
previous text or whatever that you've
already written and then autocompletes
from from that token above okay so it's
kind of a it's a weak version of auto
complete now it's actually pretty useful
if you're using a programming language
or a text file that there's no
autocomplete for and it's a feature that
Eclipse offers but very few people
actually use other features that are
that are really useful give you an
example soon are used by a broader
broader population than just one percent
but it's still you know if you have such
usage data available to you what I
encourage you to do is take a tool that
you think everybody should know or that
you
assume everybody does know and look at
how many people are actually using it my
guess is you're going to see numbers
less than twenty percent off its right
which led to it essentially that we
could do I because they found so many
features that accumulated and that in
fact some of the
Pinterest people wanted
for too hard to use
discoverable I know if they don't follow
up study to sort of understand whether
users after the rivet sort of are aware
but certainly there was a lot of work
that went in because fundamentally the
file in menu system just the traditional
banking system just been for the number
of features of the group it just wasn't
it wasn't scared myself whether the
ribbon scales I don't know but it
certainly certainly helps you discover
things i think i think the edict out
there I don't know if it's the case you
have me curious is people kept asking
them for those very features that had
already been in the product 10 years so
they were in reaching the all costly the
top of the request list for things we
had landed ten years ago but what are
they talking about and that was one of
the big drivers of the change right i
don't know if that's the same thing just
to us but still people want to ninety
nine percent but if you look at like
visual studio and eclipse they both
subscribe to sort of the old stuff yeah
user I'm just making up
yeah so I was I would actually guess
that I think there's actually a fairly
fundamental difference between word and
tools like visual studio or eclipse or
whatever and that's with word most of
the features that you want to use what
you'll find is that people have a
problem and they need and they go out
and they search for it and sometimes
they can't find it okay so they know
thats a text needs to be they want the
text darker so they're going to look
somewhat for something like bold maybe
they don't know the name of it but
they're looking for something for it all
right with eclipse what are the core
features you need to do programming you
need a compiler and need an editor the
rest of us just kind of fluff right rest
of it's just sort of productivity
enhancements whereas with word you know
everything I think well not everything
but a lot of the tools are things that
you know you know you should have it's
just a matter of finding them so you
know contrasting you know 50 years ago
against today we have more tools but
we're not really using them that much
all right so so let me put it to you
this way so this is what programming
look like 50 years ago this is kind of
what I think it looks like today all
right it's basically the same picture
but we have a pretty UI on top of the
development environments that we use
okay so my research is about helping
software developers make use of the
tools that we've got we spent a lot of
time we've spent a lot of money making
really great software development tools
things could really improve people's
productivity things that can save a lot
of time things that can help connect
people to gather things that can make
software better in general but if people
don't use them right those benefits
aren't aren't reaped so I want to talk
about sort of a slice of the research
that I've done and then I'm planning to
do and we're talk about sort of three
pretty different areas and the first one
is going to be refactoring and I'll talk
about that a little more in a minute
just we're factoring this restructuring
code talk about some refactoring tools
and some problems with those and why
people use them and don't use them then
we'll talk about discovery in general
how do people find out about features in
the tools that they use okay if they're
using eclipse how do they know that
there's a refactoring tool in it if
they're using word how do they know that
there's a compare documents feature in
it and the last one I want to talk about
is aging which is probably not the kind
of aging that we usually talk about
software aging this is actually human
aging okay how does the tools that we
use how does that change over time as we
get older okay so let's start with our
factoring so this is some work that I
did when I was in grad school that was
my PhD is based on so we'll just start
at the beginning here a little bit so
we're factoring there's been a hot topic
in the last ten years or so and our
factoring is just changing the structure
of code without changing the way that it
behaves so although it's been it's been
popular for the last ten years of course
has been done forever even what's been
done as long as we've had structured
software at least and so there's nothing
nothing particularly new about it except
that we have a name for it and we've
kind of done some categorization of
different types of refactoring so why
would we want to change the structure of
code without changing the way of behaves
right we're paid to make software that
that does something more that has fewer
bugs well a refactoring helps enable
those different types of changes so if
you need to make an enhancement changing
the structure of code may make it easier
to make that enhancement or if you need
to fix a bug changing the structure may
actually expose expose the bug in a way
that's not obvious in the code that you
have now so and we're factoring is
something like I said something that's
been around for a long time and in the
past twenty years ago if you wanted to
restructure your code know you would
you'd basically do it manually so if you
want to say rename a class okay renaming
is a typical refactoring that's that a
lot of people do you want to take a
class you pick the name before that
doesn't capture what the class does
anymore the name wasn't good for some
reason if you wanted to do it in the
past what you'd have to do is you'd have
to change the name and then find all the
references to that name and update all
the references all right and in the last
few years what you've gotten is tools to
help you do that
what we're calling we're factoring tools
and so we're factoring tools are in most
big development environments nano
Eclipse netbeans visual studio and is
plugins to those environments to and our
factoring pools don't do anything
amazing other than do what you would
normally do by hand they just automate
what you would have to do without the
tool so again take this rename example
if i have a class and i need to rename
it i can use a tool and I can you know
say this is the thing I want to rename
this is the new name and the tool knows
the semantics the program so it will
find all the references and update all
the references and so basically with
we're factoring tools you get two things
one it's basically guarantee ibly
correct okay the change that's going to
made will that it will make will not
affect the behavior of your program and
they also do it very quickly as well
even if you're you're pretty sure that a
change you're making isn't going to
change semantics you can do it much
faster with a tool that's what can do it
basically at the speed of the compiler
so that's why you might want to use a
refactoring tool over a factoring by
hand an important point here is you
always have the choice okay well if you
have a factoring tool available to you
in your development environment you can
do it with the tool or you can do it
without the tool okay and I have a
little demo here so this is some
refactoring tools and eclipse I'm going
to change the name of this results
variable okay i'm going to change it to
result set and it's going to change all
the references which is nice I don't do
one other little refactoring here which
is I'm going to take this hunk of code
and I'm going to put it into a new
method so we call extract method i'd say
extract method i made it into a method
here put a reference to that method and
i can change the name as i did before
okay so a little demo about what kind of
refactoring is about and there are
smaller factoring xin big ones bigger
ones include things like restructuring
inheritance hierarchy moving things up
and down excuse me extracting classes in
lining classes lots of different types
of refactoring so that's for factoring
and refactoring tools
so what's the problem here well we do
know that reef actor developers were
factored a lot okay whether or not they
recognize it whether they not whether or
not they sit down and say okay I'm going
to a factor right now it's something
that people just do and so we did
there's been previous work that has say
taken automated tools and look through
the version of welcome to look through
the version history of large pieces of
software and seeing where people have
changed class names taking big classes
and broken them down into smaller
classes they have observed that
refractory has happened we also did a
study where we manually looked at code
changes and found that refactoring
happens a lot happens daily hourly at a
high level and changing the the class
structure around at a low level just
changing statements around a little bit
so developers were factored a lot but
they don't use their tools very much
okay they don't use the refactoring
tools and in fact we did when we did a
study what we found was that developers
only use them about ten percent of the
time and so the methodology here is a
little it's a little complicated but I
think I can summarize it what we did is
we looked through version history okay
and we we did a random sampling of
before someone did a commit and after
they did a commit and we compared the
two together and we inferred where the
summer fact rings happen so we saw a
class that's name has changed but the
content had changed at all we said Oaks
like they did a rename refactoring okay
we did that for a bunch of different
changes and we also had refactoring tool
logs okay the people who actually made
these changes they gave us the history
of which were factoring tools they
invoked when so we were able to do with
that is we took when they use tools okay
and try to figure out they must have
done that between two different commits
alright and so we could do is we could
see her factoring in code and we can see
when they did it with the tool or
sometimes we saw our factoring in code
and there was no history of doing it
with a tool and in that case we said
they didn't do it with a tool question
only for we backed her instead
nationalist be done automatically by the
tools that's a very good question so we
when we looked originally we didn't
constrain ourselves by things that are
just available by tools or even
refactorings that have a name we were
just looking at changes and we thought
really hard about and we thought well is
this something that would have changed
behavior or not I think we found a
couple that didn't have names but for
the most part they were named and
actually for the most part there was
tool support so when I talked about ten
percent of the ten percent of the time
they didn't use tools that was only for
the refactoring for which there was tool
support okay
instrumentation flips out what's the
data collection
so so for in terms of looking through
the repository there wasn't anything
special there that was outside of
eclipse that was us looking through the
version histories in terms of
instrumentation for which tools they
were using that is inside of eclipse
eclipse keeps track of which we're
factoring is you do and it does that for
the purpose of library migration so if
you do some refactoring you can ship
those refactorings along with your code
and so any clients of your code can kind
of a rerun those refactorings on their
code and they can update it but we can
use that for our study to sort of that
to match the changes to what happened
that's right what happened to me clips
and sort of infer its whether or not the
refactoring use of the tool actually
correspond to yes that was manually
though that was yes that was manually
done yes and there are some threats
there so for instance it's possible that
we didn't get the full histories but
even if you look at even if you do a
more conservative analysis the numbers
still low the numbers only about only
goes up to about thirty percent thirty
percent over factories are done with
tools somebody actually have to turn all
the way back
for that special yes that's not right
when they turn that on then you know
that the refactoring tool is active
that's right now for certain other types
of refactorings you actually have to
explicitly say I'm doing this roof Agron
lifting yes if you use the tools you
always have to say which type of
refactoring you're doing I see so the
recordings yes that's right ok so
developers were only using the or
factoring tools about ten percent of the
time and we did a couple of different
case studies and actually that number
was quite stable we were surprised
surprised by that and I think there's a
bunch of possible reasons why people
don't use their factoring tools but I'm
going to give you one and one of them is
that they're factoring tools have poor
usability okay they're factoring tools
are have some have some problems with
the user interfaces so I'm going to give
you an example here this example says
occasionally when you do or a factoring
you try to use a tool the tool refuse to
do it will pop up an error message for
instance this one says ambiguous return
value selected block contains more than
one assignment to local variable so
maybe your maybe you're smarter than I
am but when I first saw that it was
didn't really make a lot of sense after
you know careful study it's actually it
is correct it's actually quite accurate
but at its faced it's kind of hard to
figure out what's going on and so we did
a formative study where we had people do
some summer factoring and and
occasionally they got these these error
messages and we asked them to either you
know explain what was going on tell me
what was tell me what this error message
means and all the time what they did was
they got they got most of it they gots a
75-percent of understanding with the
error message man but the other
twenty-five percent there was something
slightly off or more commonly people
just don't pay any attention to the
error messages all they say yeah okay
whatever I get that okay so I'm going to
talk about a solution to the error
message prob
them and then I'll talk about some other
usability solutions too so what we did
here was we took the error messages and
we replace them with a graphical
representation okay so what you see on
top is the graphical representation of
the same error message you saw before so
if you select this piece of code with
these pink dots okay and you try to
extract it into a new method put it into
a new method below you can't do it
because there are these two variables
that are being assigned to right and if
you try to assign to them you can only
return one or the other okay not both
and there are technical solutions to
this but basically this is what that
what the previous error message was
trying to tell you just in a graphical
form all right so we did this both we
built an implementation for Eclipse and
we also built some some prototypes so it
turns out if you look at the error
messages that were factoring tools
thrown eclipse there's a lot of them
there's actually more than i expected
there's about six hundred different
error messages that you could get from
the Eclipse for factoring tools that was
just one example so I didn't have the
time to re-implement all 600 in a
graphical form but what I did instead is
I took all 600 broke them down into a
taxonomy so similar ones are grouped
together some of them talk about data
flow some of them can talk about control
flow some of them talk about clashes
between names I took those broke them
down and then made some sort of
prototype you eyes for what what a
graphical representation of that error
message might look like sort of a more
expressive representation so and based
on those we kind of came up with some
principles for what we think a better
display of these days we're factoring
error messages look like and so for
instance the the the error
representation no matter what it is
should help me estimate the amount of
work that was work that's required to
fix the problem okay so for example we
saw that last error message that said
more than one assignment to local
variable ok how many it matters how many
because the more there are the harder it
is for me to fix the problem
another another guideline is the errors
should be distinguishable okay what we
saw with the formative study was that
people saw one error message okay and
they read it they were pretty diligent
about it and then they saw another and
they didn't even look at it because they
assumed it was the same as the first one
okay the fact that they were both kind
of in these great text boxes they both
had you know a sentence worth of text
they didn't even bother to look at the
second one so our guide line here is
that you should be able to distinguish
sort of at a glance the differences
between different error messages and
these guidelines aren't particularly new
these guidelines you can get from sort
of any standard usability text but they
are sort of specialized just for this
context these are the ones that we think
are particularly important for these
type of error messages we also think
actually they're probably generalizable
to other types of error messages that
you might get in your development
environment so we did a study on this
okay where we had we pitted the
graphical version versus the textual
version we had people do kind of some
simulated or factoring we showed them
the error messages or we showed them the
graphical version we ask them to explain
what the problem was point out what the
problem points are in the code and tell
us whether which kind of one they liked
more so kind of a standard usability
test so using the graphical version
people were faster they were about three
times fast or understanding what the
problem was they were more accurate
depending on how you measure accuracy
they were some time somewhere between
about two and ten times more accurate
using the graphical version and they
also enjoyed using using the graphical
version more when actually the two
different version to the study one way
were they gave them training with both
of the we essentially told them what
this meant and we told them that what
this meant and then we did the
experiment we did another way we didn't
tell them what either of them meant all
right and the results were consistent
there as well okay so so that's kind of
an improvement to the that the error
messages you get with our factoring
tools we did some work in some other
areas with her factoring to
so on the left this is a tool that's a
what they call a smell detector so a
smell detector is a tool that fines
fines and identifies smells the code
smell is something that's in your code
that indicates that our factoring might
be necessary okay so it's kind of a mat
called a design defect and they use the
word smell because it's something that
might possibly be wrong with your code
but you have to take a look at it first
like I'm something that smells in your
refrigerator you know if there's
probably something wrong but maybe it's
just some delicious cheese or something
and so what we did is we looked at the
existing smell detectors that we're out
there which either take the form of this
visualization that you run you run
through your whole code set and you get
this visualization and you pick through
it or you get the standard underlining
that you get in code with compiler
warnings or compiler errors and we kind
of combine these two together into this
ambient notification thing which always
stays in the same place as you're moving
around in the code it's always behind
the code and it's not intended to be in
your face but it's sort of intended to
be kind of a heads-up display to give
you some information about the code
smells and if you want more information
you can kind of click on these
individual pedals and it'll tell you
it'll give you a deeper explanation of
what's going on there so it's kind of a
different way to display static analysis
results we did some experiments there
too which were good and then another
problem that we tackled with our
factoring tools is so so so it's been
brought up one problem with for
factoring or 11 thing about refactoring
tools is you always have to know which
we're factoring you want to do before
you do it okay so things like rename
people were pretty good at I'm about to
rename a class they recognize that but
there's a lot of other refactorings that
maybe aren't so obvious so for instance
what is introduced in Direction mean
okay if you were going to introduce in
direction all right by hand would you
know to go to a menu item that said
introduced in direction and our feeling
was know the names aren't actually
particularly good indicators of
which of what the restructuring does so
we did instead is rather than having
people rely on the names we had we used
gestures and said we had kind of this
this model of where refactoring should
appear in a gesture so it's kind of nice
about refactoring is are somewhat
structural so things like pushing
methods up and down pushing pushing
fields up and down naturally kind of
belongs in an up and down position okay
so if you want to invoke the refactoring
we implemented this with pi menus so
rather than going to the menu and saying
or going to your context menu and saying
pull up you can just kind of gesture in
the up direction or if you don't know
which direction is you can invoke the PI
menu so used to you know you can use
your mouse or you can do a hot keys
hotkey scheme with that too another nice
thing about why we're factoring lend
themselves well to sort of this
directional scheme is that a lot of
times we're factoring czar opposite
things like extract method and in line
method those kind of naturally lend
themselves to being on opposite in
opposite directions and so we leverage
that to to put refactorings on these PI
menus and we did a we didn't do if
having done a field study with that yet
but what we did do is we showed that
people can intuitively if we show them
if we show them where these items appear
on the menu they can kind of form a
mental model of where they should appear
and can recreate that what's even cooler
is if you show some examples and you ask
them to do a factoring that you've never
showed them before okay but naturally
fits with the model they can actually
guess pretty well which direction they
should gesture to invoke that refractory
right which suggests that they don't
actually need to know the name of their
factoring to use it and one other piece
of work so so this is with with tools
but I'm also interested in not only how
developers use the tools that they use
but also i'm interested in the languages
language features that they use to so
for instance this is a study that I did
with Chris parnan and chris byrd where
we were looking at java generics
okay we wanted to sort of evaluate some
of the claims about Java generics
because nobody there hasn't really been
many empirical studies on it and
certainly no large-scale empirical
studies so one of the claims about
generic so generics are things like if
you have a collection you want to type
that collection you want to say what the
items are in that collection so if you
have a list maybe you want to say it's a
list of strings one claim with that is
that if you use generics then you can
reduce the number of casts you have in
your program kass kass allow you to
force the type system to recognize that
when you say get something out of a
collection it is of this specific type
and you have to use a cast to do that
and so there's always been this claim
that generic should help reduce casts so
we evaluated that and it turns out it
works that's true sometimes but a lot of
the times it's not so in this graph what
we have is the number of casts and a
program normalized for program length
okay so you see it's relatively there's
there's some initial turmoil and then it
kind of it's kind of more or less flat
and then the blue line is the number of
number of generics essentially ok we see
that generics were actually introduced
in 2004 and so we see a little bit of
generic use from then on and some
increasing use and as people are using
generics more and more we don't actually
see a big change in the number of casts
in a program and there didn't seem to be
a strong correlation between the two so
you know this is interesting too because
it tells us something about how people
actually are adopting the language
features that they're adopting when
they're doing it and whether the ideas
that we have about how people should be
using using language features are really
panning out okay so I want to return
back to our factoring a little bit so
here's our development environment
here's eclipse so suppose that I've made
we've got these great refactoring tools
my research has this huge impact Eclipse
totally changes the way that we're
factoring tools are made or Microsoft
now goes out and changes all of its for
factoring tools they're all totally
usable they're great so now are people
going to use the
factoring tools that we've given them
are we going to see this this big uptick
I think we'll see some but are they
going to find the factoring item on the
menu are they going to click on it my
guess is no because the way that if you
don't use for factoring tools the way
that you see our development environment
is like this doesn't really don't even
really recognize that there is or a
factoring menu kind of just skip over it
right and this is this isn't a bad thing
right this is how we deal with complex
environments like this is we don't you
know we don't have to understand
everything about it we skip over the
things that we don't understand and
sometimes we come back you know and try
to figure out what they what they are
but a lot of the times we just blank
them out and so for me there's a lot of
things in eclipse that I don't know what
it does and don't wreck but I don't
don't register for me and all those kind
of appear as I just skip over all right
when im using my development environment
and so all of these are kind of our kind
of unused and so no matter how you know
good the usability is of these
particular features in my development
environment if i don't really recognize
them i don't even try them okay i'm not
i won't use them so give you one other
example of this so this is the open
resource tool in Eclipse you may not
have used it but you've almost certainly
used a tool just like it so the way open
resource works is if you use the open
resource command it'll bring up a dialog
box that look like this you can type
start typing something and the
characters that you type will match the
different files that Eclipse knows about
so and it also works with camel case
which is kind of neat and so it's it's
actually it's a really good tool it's
quite it's pretty usable it could be a
little better but it's quite good and if
you look online what people are saying
about it they really like it so it's you
know number one on the list of the ten
navigation shortcuts every programmer
should know it's one of the most useful
tools and eclipse it's a command that i
use religiously and it's the biggest
time-saver I've stumbled upon so this is
this is this is a tool that a lot of
people really
like all right and Eclipse but if you
again if you look at who's using it and
who's not if you say take a one month I
took may 2009 only about twelve percent
of people actually use who use Eclipse
actually use open resource so even
though the tool is really fantastic it's
really great it's actually independent
of whatever programming environment you
whatever programming language you use
it'll work for anything when you're
using resources people a lot of people
still don't use it okay and maybe
because they don't know about it so so
what I wanted to know about this is what
you really want to know is why aren't
people using those tools why didn't they
find about find out about a tool and
that's a hard question to answer and so
what I did instead is well if we if we
can't figure out what's not working
let's figure out what is working okay
let's find out about how people really
do discover tools right so if you're
working in this environment how might
you find out about refactoring tools so
we came up with a list of different
possible ways that you might discover a
new tool and we just sort of brainstorm
these this is work with Gail Murphy so
for instance we said one way you might
discover new tools through something
will call peer observation where you
observe someone else using a tool while
their programming that you didn't know
about so say you're doing pair
programming you see someone else use a
tool okay are you just walking to the
office and you see them use it and say
hey that was cool what did you just do
you learn it that way or kind of the
opposite thing happens we'll call it
peer recommendation where someone
observes you programming and suggest a
new tools so you know you're doing
something slightly efficiently actually
there's a tool inefficiently there's
there's a tool that actually does that
better for you you'll save you a bunch
of steps it'll save you a bunch of time
there's tool encounter where you just
happen to find tool by exploring the
user interface of your development
environment or any other any other
environment like Microsoft Word a
tutorial you're reading or watching a
tutorial and that mentions a new tool
and you discover
that way there's sort of written
descriptions like standard standard
textbook or will will lump web pages in
there too so you're reading through one
of these publications and it mentions a
tool you could also discover a tool
through Twitter or RSS feeds
occasionally you'll see tweets where
someone says if you're in Eclipse and
you press alt shift T it does this cool
thing of course 140 characters or less
which which is kind of tough but it is
one way that you could discover we have
seen people at least broadcasting that
they've discovered new tools and the
last thing we thought of is discussion
thread where you learn about a new tool
after reading it on a list of comments
or a foreign or an email discussion and
what we're really interested in here is
examples of where someone discovers a
new tool where they didn't know they had
a problem okay where it's not that
they're going out to find a solution
okay it's not that they're going to
search google or not that they're going
to go ask a friend it's that they find
something that they didn't they didn't
know about in the past okay so we've got
these seven different categories and
what we want to know about them is how
often do they happen okay and how well
do they work okay are they effective if
you learn a tool if you discover tool
via one of these methods how likely are
you to use it three months later or six
months later so what we did is for
frequency all right we asked we asked
people just to tell us some stories okay
we did we did interviews this is the
first study that we've done we did
interviews with developers and we said
we'll give them a list of different
tools we had a bunch of tools from Emacs
a bunch of different tools from vam a
bunch of tools from Visual Studio and a
bunch of tools from eclipse we said now
here's a development environment might
you might use here's a tool tell me how
you discovered that tool how did you
find out about it in the first place
people told us told us stories and what
we assumed was the more frequent they
told the story all right the more
frequent the type the more likely that
type happened so for instance if
everybody told us that they discovered
their that tool from Twitter we would
say that Twitter is a frequent mechanism
for discovering new tools now that
relies on people's memories which is
which is questionable
and I can answer any questions about
that why we think that was an okay
method to use so that's how we how we
figured out frequency and I'll give you
the results in a second an effectiveness
we asked people to self rate
effectiveness so we said here are seven
different categories of ways that you
could learn about a new tool tell me
what you think the most effective way is
what's the best way that works for you
in terms of using the tool again later
in the future alright and so here's what
the results looked like each of these
boxes represents a single person's
response and so what you find is that
tool encounter the one at the top that's
what people mentioned as the most common
way they discovered a new tool okay they
were poking through the user interface
they said oh there's we're factoring
menu I wonder wonder what this does and
they try it and previous results
actually predict that that's not a big
surprise it turned out that that is the
most frequent way that people discover
new tools what previous results don't
tell us is whether it's really effective
or not and the answer to that according
to the people we interviewed was
actually no okay it's actually not
particularly effective especially
compared to learning it from someone
else okay so we did the study partially
because we were especially interested in
these first two learning socially from
someone else and what we found is
wondering from someone else actually
doesn't happen particularly frequently
but people like doing it a lot it's
quite effective and so the challenge
here is it's it's it's interact this
this will call these two together peer
interaction interacting with appear so
why is it effective and why is it why
doesn't it happen often okay so we've
got some answers to that based on the
interviews so why does it work so well
to learn from someone else well it works
well because typically the person that
you learn from is someone that you work
with as part of as part of your normal
work if someone's likely to walk over to
you and look over your shoulder that's
probably someone you work with rather
than someone random who comes off comes
in off the street so there's a hot
there's a high probability of relevance
there what's also nice about this is the
tool is demonstrated on a real problem
it's not like you have to you have to
come up with a contrived example of why
this tool is
right you get to see it in the context
of use so it's on a real problem the the
water feels like she discovered it
herself which is which is nice so when
when you see someone else do it you
don't it's not necessarily like someone
is forcing it upon you it's more like
its kind of self-discovery which people
reported was important to them the
learner associates the tool with the
context of use which makes it memorable
okay so they see that the tool used in
its context and what they report is next
time they're in the context they see if
they think of using the tool again
alright so why doesn't it happen
frequently anybody want to take a guess
why learning from someone else wouldn't
happen frequently programmers I have a
lot of friends great okay nobody nobody
mentioned that nobody want nobody wanted
to own up to that okay what do you think
that what do you think they reported as
the biggest barrier to learning from
someone else
don't want to show your toys utility
okay yeah that'll that'll come in wasn't
the number one so the number one thing
was of course physical isolation okay
people not not being in the situation
where they would naturally you know look
over someone's shoulder but that's kind
of obvious right I mean lots of people
work from home at least at least part of
the time or in some cases people work
from home a lot so physical isolation
makes this hard but not impossible some
people talk to us about talk to us about
doing some remote pair programming with
someone else they weren't using anything
fancy like video conferencing but what
they were doing is they had a remote vim
session open and they had a chat chat
session open and they they switch back
and forth and one of them reported it as
you know I saw some I saw some texts
move around on the screen and then I had
to ask my pair my buddy what was going
on with that and then he explained oh if
you press these this particular
combination of keys you get that effect
alright so physical isolation makes it
hard but not impossible different
programming environments definitely
makes this hard you know if if some
people on your team are using Emacs and
some of them are using using visual
studio than different programming
environments the two can't warn from
each other say quite as much as they
could if they were using the same
programming environment but even if they
are using the same programming
environment at some point your team is
going to kind of you might call it
annealing right they all get to the kind
of the same level of tool tool
proficiency so once you know once I've
learned a lot from you at some point
there's not going to be much more than I
can learn assuming you're not learning
new tools outside of that relationship
so acclimation to each other's tool sets
is one reason this does this may not
happen very often sometimes company
policy dictates which tool you should
use this one came up a few times and so
you know if the company says you must
use visual studio and and you don't have
a choice even though you see your friend
using something else you don't have a
choice to switch then obviously that's
that's a barrier to learning from
someone else however even within the
even if your dip
quickly the dick when someone dictates
you must use this tool typically it's a
high-level tool something big like
visual studio or something big like an
eclipse and even within that there's
lots of new features or new tools that
you can learn time pressure makes this
hard for sure if you're working under a
deadline people reported well I don't
have the time to you know share my
knowledge with someone else so when
there's time pressure sometimes people
don't share and sometimes there's an
unwillingness to this was kind of rare
but some people talked about sometimes
people in the organization we're not
willing to share a tool with someone
else partially because that is kind of
what makes developers proficient
sometimes what gives them their skills
as the tool sets that they use right
it's kind of a kind of what give kind of
it's kind of like if I told you about my
tools I'd be giving away my secret sauce
so another reason why it doesn't happen
very often so here's the research
challenge for me so what we know okay is
that Peter action doesn't happen very
often but it works really well so if we
can make it happen more often okay
people actually like doing it they're
not forced into a situation where they
don't want to do it if people have the
opportunity to learn from others more
alright they'll probably learn more
tools so how can we make how can we sort
of tackle the number one problem people
working in different places how are
people who work remotely and say
asynchronously working on different
parts of the globe at different times
how can they learn from each other okay
so i'll give you a proposal all right so
one way we can have developers learn
from each other if they're working
asynchronously is that for each
developer and we'll just keep this say
into into one team we won't talk about
the global ecosystem of developers for
one developer will keep track of what
tool she's using ok so you know each
time you use a tool make a make a note
all right and we've got we've got
certainly got infrastructure to do that
and also keep a full movie or a full
screen cast the developers history from
beginning to end ok just a full a full
screen cast all right so any time you
want to you can go back in time and you
can see what you are doing last week or
you can see what you're doing last month
so you're a lot of you're probably
thinking okay there's privacy issues
here I'm not going to let anybody else
see this sort of thing we could talk
about that but what we can do with this
data is we can look at the the tool
histories okay we can compare them
between say all developers on your team
all right and using by doing the
comparison we can use something like say
collaborative filtering to make
recommendations about tools okay we can
say that you know there's one there's
one tool that I don't use that everybody
else on my my team knows about okay and
maybe I should know about that too now
we've actually built or Gail Murphy has
built a tool with a master student where
they actually did make recommendations
like this all right and one difficulty
of these sorts of just making
recommendations just saying you know
everybody else uses this but you don't
as people don't people don't take very
well to those sort of recommendations we
get to the clippy problem right people
don't like these sorts of
recommendations where they're kind of
sort of sort of out of context but what
we can do is we if we can if we take
take recommendations from individual
people and we say you know who it is
who's making the recommendation and
maybe if we just connect people together
they'll learn from each other so what we
could do is we could say you know call
one guy Rob and the other Tim we could
say Rob your coworker team uses open
source would you like to see an example
of him using it yesterday ok again
privacy issues you'll have to be some
mediation going on here but what you can
do is you can you can go through Tim's
history you can go back in time to the
last time he used it or one time before
that you can take out a little
screencast ship it off to the network
and then Rob can learn from what he did
ok it's not it's not synchronous because
you can because this person did it in
the past and doesn't require any extra
effort because the the examples already
there I think it's so great I guess to
what task is mr. the bush yesterday but
it amazing sort of haha working on some
cookies but little studio and I wrote a
really long email I have this problem
here's the way I think that at this
moment he said odf knock her chat and so
like he called me up and then said we
share you know your screen so I can see
like visually what's happening
communicator I just said ok I understand
that but what you meant in that long
email and then he says okay can I see
the source code now any browser I said
well you know this other thing that I
did is similar to what you want to do
and like in five minutes like we were
done right so i mean i think that i like
the making peer interaction or frequent
here was a guy across campus and just
the ability I mean email was like stupid
assured of home I said look at what's
happening the app I don't want this to
happen and then we could have had this
like really high bandwidth discussion
instead I SAT for like 20 minutes
receive it out try to make it sort of
perfect description formal tags so I
think somehow somehow there's you can't
get face-to-face you can talk to the
person if you can't talk to the person
than these sort of things but I think
one should say don't have a priority
right that like first I should really
talk to the sink I who's the expert in
this code base and if I can't if I can't
do that you know then then I need these
these then I need these proxies for the
person right leg that what they did but
it was sort of even before I would start
the history I would like just make it
easier within an organization
to just contact people to get their time
this guy actually happened very willing
to share his time suggested wows share
your computer screen with me wow that's
in the whole idea and you know five
minutes later we were done so I would
just encourage you to think that they
quieter than just the direct
communication wow I really solve my
problem quickly yes such a happy camper
has that been a spent I could have spent
hours drilling down into the code and
browsing and thinking and learning the
code yeah that might have been
worthwhile in the end give me a solution
which is good enough away so I guess
there's also that belly so sort of
I have a task to get done versus browse
this data may be relevant not a deal I
made get some learning from it all the
way to get right so I'm hearing is that
the timing is definitely important and
this doesn't address it at all when you
interrupt someone or if you don't
interrupt if you wait for them to go out
and get get the information they need
yeah it's an open open question but I
mean the title is absolutely right on
that enabling that but then the whole
business the privacy in history
excellent you know I can't imagine like
if this bag we reported what he done
like the little tidbit he gave me would
have been captured them proud I would
have found it I'm just not sure maybe
that's an interesting searching problem
that right I've got something that I
want to do that that's like some things
buddy else in this case whispered it
seems like they were different
also investors
that's here which is going to completely
unfair opportunities to be captured
there's another level of investment
which is authoring some people will put
together blog to out you know love this
tool here's why to use of yours having
is
there's another level which is this real
time of the shoulder over the shoulder
area of the shoulder so what this peer
interaction really mean like it's
mediated via blog so i was taking
pietrzak dinner actually more literally
as people with interactive direct right
now we're at dawn circa not be an
artifact I don't think you know you're
going to nail one the other two look no
no I'm not I'm not suggesting that it
well I'm just saying that the sort of
things here are not our proxy for Peter
but it's okay thanks good points so so
this so in this first situation I'm
talking about we're saying you know
there's something you don't know maybe
you should find out about it okay and
that may or may not work people may not
want to go out and sort of admit their
admit their ignorance of something but
you could do it you could flip it around
to as you could say to the other guy you
could say Rob your coworker or Tim your
coworker Rob doesn't seem to know about
open resource would you like to share an
example of him using with it so the
example that you just brought up of say
putting it on your blog for example that
might be kind of an indirect way to do
it or you could just kind of take that
snippet of your of your your history you
know and putting it saying on facebook
friends that might help too yep wait
around weeks ago
which is a
pure competition
the idea of trying to help people
discover
abilities a ribbon tool
achievements yet
and which was just I think the mean was
just about like here's some achievements
that would be personally interesting for
you to do it as an individual but I
suppose we could explore the same space
the team reversal
the ones I would learn from yeah yeah
sure yeah the gaming at the gaming acts
but aspect could definitely be leveraged
just worked well for things like
stackoverflow where there's a certain
level of you know the more points you
get the how the higher status you are
but yeah as you said even you know
within your own team I think one class
one open question there though is how
much do people actually value that I
don't know so you can take another
example like oh lo ok which rates open
source developers against one another
that one I'm not sure that people
actually take seriously or not so what
student something like stackoverflow
what people I would guess people take
more seriously than then they took
overflow so I think you know using kind
of using what we've learned about games
in the past in the development context
could is definitely promising for sure
ok great so you know maybe one solution
to making peer interaction more frequent
I want to share one other thing that we
noticed by doing these interviews and
that discovery didn't happen uniformly
across different groups of people and
one thing we actually noticed that there
was an age difference between older
developers and younger software
developers so someone from an older
teammate in a group said the junior
members tend to be more voracious in
their desire to learn new api's and
tools and stay plugged into what's going
on with languages and stuff my time is
spent digging into more bugs and more
things that I'm responsible for
delivering and I have less time to do
independent research no one's upset when
a junior member says they have a better
way to do things we kind of saw the same
effect from the younger side too so
someone younger teammates said there's a
fair amount of bias towards me teaching
other engineers something I'm a student
in intern in the process of warning as
many tools as I can from learning as
much as I can from as many tools as I
can several developers I know especially
those that have 10 20 30 40 years of
experience tend to say that they have
say that they know the tools that they
use and they don't necessarily have the
time or more commonly the patience to
sit down and fiddle with a new tool and
I don't know about you but that kind of
that sort of resonates with my
experience too so it was interesting
that there's there's sort of this
dynamic where the tool knowledge maybe
comes in to the younger developers where
they have time to mess around and poke
through the user interface and you know
waste their time not actually developing
software but but but playing with the
tools they have and kind of filtering up
socially to to the older software
developers and I think that's kind of I
want to kind of go off into talk a
little bit more abstractly about this I
think there's something there we've you
know we know a little bit about gender
say gender differences between software
developers but we don't actually know
much from an aging perspective and we
have recent we have reason to suggest
that it's important so for example the
study that I just talked about it
suggests that technology introduction
often starts with younger workers and
eventually maybe reaching older adults
assuming that the Peter interaction
actually happens but one other
interesting thing happened was that
older adults reported they were actually
both less likely to learn and teach
others via peer interaction and that was
somewhat unexpected learning less I
could believe that they're you know
they're experts they've been at it for a
while but teaching less was actually was
actually a surprise okay they said that
it actually happened less often then
then their younger peers and if you look
at sort of the other other literature
there's not much about software
development but there's certainly a lot
of research into aging and certainly
aging and technology if we look at that
we can also get sort of perspective on
aging so other studies have suggested
that there's a there's a belief in
practice that technology careers are
very intense and focused so you know
stereotypically we think that you know
it's it's a young man's game and you
know between the ages of 10 30 you know
you're going to be working 80 hours a
week or something and then after that
what happens right you burn out and so
now what if we thought about how could
that be what's what's going on there why
are people say you know not why isn't
why are so few people interested in
continuing continuing new software
development after this after these
intense careers maybe they need to be
less less intense and finally you know
if we kind of look at other sort of
physical and cognitive
factors that tells us some interesting
things too so for instance as we get
older our ability to filter out
irrelevant visual information goes down
so for instance what you might notice is
kind of by analogy it happens it happens
in audio too if you know if you're at a
party and there's a bunch of noises
going on bunch of other conversations
and you're having a conversation with
one person typically your ability you
can filter out the other information you
can filter out the other of
conversations and you can focus on your
one purse on the one person and the same
happens visually okay typically you have
your one task and you can filter out
other parts of the the whatever task
you're working on if you're adding
numbers and there's dollar signs you can
filter out those dollar signs because
they're not relevant to your task but as
it turns out as you get older your
ability to filter out the visual
information not relevant to your task
goes down okay I think this is
interesting because development
environments are really really
complicated and we talked about you know
filtering how it's important to be able
to filter out features in your
development environment so that you can
kind of deal with effectively maybe you
know because of this factor our ability
to deal with the complexity of our
development environments goes down as
well just kind of some speculation yeah
yeah mr. yeah that's a good one for sure
oh there we go
so and so kind of this is this is a
little more far-reaching I don't have
much much research to show on this but I
think we don't have a very good
understanding of the opportunities and
challenges faced by older adults and
software development I think we can we
have a lot to learn there so I wanted to
leave you with just this just this one
last slide kind of summarizing what
we've talked about so with our factoring
they're kind of still some open
questions here so how does increase
usability of tools translate to
increased use kind of in general how can
we communicate effectively with our
development environment our environment
has a lot of things to tell us it's got
lots of information that we that it
would like us to be aware of static
analysis information compiler
information how can we effectively
communicate with it in terms of
discovery what personal practice is
ignoring you know the technology
solutions what personal practices can
developers follow to stay aware of new
tools is it about you know spending a
lot of time on lifehacker looking for
interesting pieces of software is it
about spending more time pair
programming spending an hour a week
doing it and rotating between
programmers don't know and how can
physically is we talked about how can
physically distributed developers
discover discover tools from one another
and in terms of aging you know how can
we effectively how can we lengthen the
effective working career of the software
developer and is that even something
that we want to do and what challenges
and opportunities to older adults face
and software development okay so so this
is I'm I'll be around for the rest of
the week like I said and so if you'd
like to meet with me I would be happy to
talk with you you've got some great
examples I'd like to hear them like to
hear about your experience so thank you
questions written up in a white paper of
some sort or the the aging part just
it's the whole presentation in general
um it's several references
oh yeah there isn't there isn't a single
single unifying paper this is this this
is this presentation is probably it but
you can look for my NSF Career Award
which will probably be quite similar
other questions points of contention I
don't agree with this yeah so I need to
do to like research in Beijing but did
you get any sense or whether if at all
there was transition between younger and
older developers like our technologies
adopted because younger golfers are
sharing or because it's just a
generational shift that's a few
questions I think I don't have so your
point is that there are sort of two two
different factors that might be going on
one you know in terms of learning new
features one of them is that maybe
people are using the same tools just
because that's what they started with
right and they're continuing to use them
and the other one is maybe they
transition to new tools because they
find out about them through some
mechanism and I don't know I actually
can't say much about whether you know
one happens more than the other which
which factor is more important but
there's definitely there's definitely
you know in addition to you know your
ability to be in the situation where
you're going to learn something from
someone else there's also kind of your
willingness your willingness to learn
something from someone else and sort of
the one of our interview responded
respondents kind of called it developer
inertia or you know you've got what you
have and it works pretty well so why
should you why should you transition to
some tool that may or may not save you a
few seconds but so it's a good question
I don't know the questions or comments
okay thanks all thank you all for coming